was lippenstifte für eine bedeutung
haben das seht ihr heute und ich wünsche
euch viel spaß mit dem video ein roter
lippenstift heißt willst heute gut
aussehen aber bitte nicht geküsst werden
bei pink ist ungefähr das gleiche
würdest du entweder 80 jahre alt bist
oder irgendwie in deiner barbie welt
gefangen keine ahnung warum es mit
krippen stiftung brauner lippenstift
heißt es entweder ein gothic oder was
viele book cosmopolitan fashion zeit
schuppen gelesen doch gut heissen die
letzten drei tage wahrscheinlich im
jogginganzug verbracht hast und heute
mal der elegant aussieht - keine und
stift heißt es einfach keine zeit um die
gedanken über den lippenstift zu machen
oder noch viel zu viel um die ohren hat
solche lippen heißen du hast viel zu
viel zeit und sollte sie recht langsam
einen job das sind einfach blind
ich habe blut auf meinen lippen kriegt
ne scheiße
ach ja falls ihr euch fragt was das ist
es sind so krebs
man fühlt sich das nächste mal mit
lippenstift oder machen damit man das
nicht sieht ironie des schicksals